is russia facing its biggest economic
storm in 20 years did russian president
vladimir putin expect such a massive
economic political and military
punishment will the russian economy be
able to withstand this tsunami of sorts
exactly how far are the allies willing
to go listen up
[Music]
moscow has carried out the largest
military offensive in europe since 1945
an offensive that has left us with
images we thought we would never see
again in old europe we were wrong tanks
heavy artillery aerial combat and the
bombing of cities are back of course
this time far from receiving the cheers
accolades and popular acclaim for
battlefield victories putin has been met
with a huge tsunami of losses
condemnations and punishments from
across the globe
the russian invasion of ukraine marks a
turning point it threatens our entire
post-war order in this situation it is
our duty to help ukraine to the best of
our ability to defend itself against
vladimir putin's invading army olaf
schultz chancellor of germany
we will show that a reckless act of
violence comes with a huge price the
international community's relationship
with russia can no longer be the same as
before fumio kashida prime minister of
japan the allies warned russia again and
again and again we're ready to impose
severe sanctions on russia if it further
invades ukraine the cruel and
unjustified invasion of ukraine would
have devastating consequences for their
society their economy and also for the
russian army itself and so visualpolitik
viewers in this video we are going to
tell you exactly how the united states
european union and in general all nato
allies seek to damage erode and even
destroy the economy and much of the
power of russia and take note because
they want to achieve this despite the
fact that the russian bear will continue
to be a major exporter of oil natural
gas and raw materials so the challenge
is enormous
[Music]
the question is how on earth can they
put it off in what ways could vladimir
putin be stopped in his tracks how are
the allies punishing russia for the
invasion of ukraine well let's take a
look
but let's wait a minute because many of
you have asked us if there is any way to
help ukraine in this war and the truth
is that there is in addition to showing
your condemnation of the invasion the
central bank of ukraine is accepting
donations from all over the world to
support the ukrainian armed forces and
the ukrainian resistance this is not
advertising obviously nobody pays us to
say this we do it for information
purposes only because we think that some
of you may find it useful and if you are
interested we have left a link in the
description
[Music]
driving russia out of the global economy
[Music]
the war is being waged on many different
battlefronts and one of them is
precisely that of the economic war the
united states the united kingdom and the
european union were very clear if putin
invaded ukraine russia would face
unprecedented punishment and guess what
no sooner said than done this is exactly
what they are doing not only to try to
stop the war but also and perhaps above
all to limit the power threat and
influence of russia if the invasion of
ukraine has made one thing clear it is
that in the end a country with few
resources has many limitations
insufficient supplies old equipment poor
training and a long list of problems of
all kinds no matter how much propaganda
there is reality ends up rearing its
head
[Music]
russia is a relatively poor and highly
corrupt country so their military as
large as it is has more holes in it than
a swiss cheese as we've all seen when it
comes down to it the russian armed
forces suffer from all kinds of
shortcomings which obviously has
consequences for example sources
indicate that during just the first five
or six days of the invasion russians
suffered more casualties in ukraine than
the united states suffered in
afghanistan throughout 20 years
[Music]
leaving the physical battle aside as
we've already told you the aim is to
punish putin and limit russia's economic
capacity as long as russia remains
hostile of course many of you may say
yeah yeah josh here we go again with the
usual comments that sound very
smart but then when it comes to the
crunch practically nothing eventuates
well you can believe me when i tell you
that this time the allies are very very
serious the invasion of ukraine has
changed everything and that is why their
first objective has been to kick russia
out of the international financial
system
firstly the sanctions are intended to
reduce foreign financing for the russian
government banks and companies to make
this happen the allies have approved
limitations on debt purchases and
sanctions against the country's major
banks the united states for example has
blocked among several others the
country's two main banks spare bank and
vtb which together control almost 60 of
the russian financial system and can no
longer operate with the u.s banks
[Music]
in other words they cannot carry out
operations in dollars and of course most
of the international operations are
carried out precisely in dollars but it
is not only the united states the united
kingdom and the european union have
followed suit a move that has left
russia trembling the second course of
action has been perhaps the most
anticipated of all the expulsion of many
russian banks from the so-called swift
system the international messaging
system that connects most of the world's
banks
swift a belgian-based cooperative is an
interbank communication system that is
involved in more than half of all
high-value cross-border payments every
day it processes more than 40 million
financial messages between more than 11
000 financial institutions worldwide
[Music]
well now a major chunk of russian banks
will be excluded from this system and
take note because when in 2012
iranian banks were expelled from swift
they suffered a catastrophe suddenly
they could no longer handle
international transfers because they
could no longer communicate or verify
them in the case of russia not all banks
will be affected or at least not
completely after all the europeans want
to continue to buy russian oil and gas
and they'll have to be able to pay for
it what's more there are the debts that
the russians have contracted with the
western banks and which obviously they
want to recover and we're talking about
121 billion nevertheless the damage to
the russian financial system will be
more than considerable because whilst
there are alternatives to swift they are
more expensive they entail control
problems and many banks will never be
compensated for using them so one way or
another the excluded russian banks will
no longer have access to a significant
part of the world's financial system
which as you can imagine will complicate
and make trade foreign investment or for
that matter the management of
remittances complicated and expensive in
other words it's a huge kick in the shin
[Music]
and then finally we have the third
course of action while the expulsion
from swift has been the most high
profile sanction of all let's take a
moment because the real blow has been
the decision of the united states the
european union the united kingdom and
canada and more countries may follow to
block the central bank of russia and
with it most of its international
reserves you see as we covered in a
previous video one of vladimir putin's
greatest trump cards were the more than
600 billion dollars in reserves that
russia has accumulated over the last few
years in the form of dollars euros gold
yuan yen etc etc check it out
[Music]
one out most of these huge reserves the
fifth largest in the world at least the
russian government can no longer draw
them
this is a kind of financial nuclear bomb
that is falling on russia the war came
and the money ran out the money ran out
sooner than the war ended sergey
alexenko former deputy finance minister
and former deputy governor of russia's
central bank cash reserves are needed to
pay for imports and also to support the
local currency for example in view of
the capital flight and the outflow of
investments caused by the war and
sanctions the central bank of russia no
longer has the necessary resources to
support the ruble which will cause it to
collapse dealing a heavy blow to the
entire country inflation will skyrocket
real incomes will plummet and savings
well the value of savings will volatize
this is the process that argentinians
are all too familiar with plain and
simple all of a sudden overnight the
blockade of the central bank has
snatched the equivalent of hundreds of
billions of dollars from the russian
government we are talking about a
measure that until now had only been
taken against iran venezuela and north
korea russia russia what a distinguished
club you've joined unsurprisingly all of
this has forced the russian government
to take measures some of them very
severe
[Music]
shortly after the major sanctions were
announced the central bank of russia in
an attempt to stem capital flights and
the consequent plunge in the ruble had
to raise interest rates to 20 percent
from the previous 9.5 percent this of
course has very negative effects on
russian companies and families the
government has also had to impose tight
capital controls that for example
prevent russians from sending money
abroad freely and that stop
international investors from liquidating
their investments in the russian stock
market
let's see who is the brave one who
invests in russia anytime soon and
remember we are not only talking about
the united states the uk and the
european union many other countries such
as japan south korea australia canada
norway and singapore are also imposing
sanctions on russia even neutral
switzerland has joined in kicking
putin's government for goodness sake
switzerland backs full eu sanctions
against russia
norway's 1.3 trillion oil fund to ditch
russian investments but it doesn't end
here because once the allies expel
russia from the international financial
system they also want to isolate it
check it out
[Music]
russia more alone than ever
[Music]
you see along with financial sanctions
the allies are also passing trade
sanctions that for example prevent
russia from buying critical products
such as technologically advanced
components at the same time the risk of
violating some of these sanctions as
well as the reputational risk is causing
many companies to announce that they are
going to cancel all or a major part of
their operations in russia this is the
case with volvo daimler disney apple
nike jaguar bp shell equino intel ups
fedex and amd among many many others and
of course the country is also being
suspended from all kinds of cultural and
sporting bodies and competitions from
eurovision to the world cup
fifa and uefa suspend all russian clubs
and national teams but if there's one
area where we are beginning to see what
the isolation of russia really entails
it is none other than aviation
[Applause]
the european union the united states the
united kingdom and canada have all
closed their airspace to russian
aircraft
our airspace will be closed to every
russian plane and that includes the
private jets of oligarchs ursula van der
lion president of the european
commission and not only that the allies
have also established strong
restrictions on the sale of all goods
and technology linked to aircraft in
other words if an aircraft goes to
russia and for example has a problem the
airline risks being stranded because it
won't be able to get the parts it needs
that is why many international airlines
are suspending their flights to russia
what's more the european union has also
banned aircraft leasing companies from
working with russian airlines and take
note because more than half of the
commercial aircraft in russia are leased
which is a very normal operation in the
industry between one thing and another
russian skies are going to be very empty
[Music]
you could say that russia is being fully
expelled from the international
community and it follows that without
money without communications and with
restrictions of all kinds you could
probably guess what the future of its
economy is going to be like well i can
say it looks bad very bad for putin and
for russia
on top of all this in addition to all
the financial and trade sanctions the
trio of major allies the united states
the european union and the united
kingdom have also targeted russian
oligarchs close to the kremlin along
with government heavyweights many of
them are going to be investigated have
their assets frozen and be banned from
entry and guess what even monaco has
joined in this task we are targeting
oligarchs private jets we will be
targeting their properties we'll be
targeting other possessions that they
have liz trusts british foreign
secretary so i don't know it is not so
unusual that it is precisely the
oligarchs in putin's own entourage who
are the first to start questioning the
invasion
top russian oligarchs are speaking out
against the war in ukraine oh oh they're
surely going to miss the high life
this visualpolitik fans is the other war
the war that the allies are waging
against russia but remember it's still a
war the punishment also extends to the
military field yes yes that's right
listen up
weapons weapons and more weapons an
enormous arsenal
vladimir putin looked very very smug the
ukrainian army would be no match against
the formidable russian mobilization
however as you all know the story has
been completely different so far russian
troops have encountered a much much more
robust and better equipped army than
they had initially thought
[Music]
and not only that after the invasion
supplies from nato and allied countries
started arriving like there was no
tomorrow at first countries like germany
were reluctant to supply arms to ukraine
in fact they even vetoed deliveries of
german-made weapons to other countries
such as estonia but then everything
changed suddenly the pressure from the
united states the united kingdom poland
and the baltic countries had an effect
now everyone has realized that every day
that the ukrainians resist things get
worse much worse for russia
precisely because of this the vast
majority of european governments are
announcing massive arms deliveries to
the ukrainian army anti-tank weapons air
defense systems ammunition food supply
vests rifles etc etc etc even the eu
itself has announced that it will use
its peace fund to finance the purchase
of armaments for ukraine this is the
first time in history that the european
union has earmarked funds for the
purchase of military equipment
and obviously all this has made the
ukrainian army better able to resist and
cause great damage to the russian army
an army for which every day of combat
costs a fortune it does not have as well
as a lot of casualties indeed even
sweden has joined this huge campaign the
scandinavian country has pledged to send
more than 5 000 anti-tank missiles and
thousands of vests and helmets along
with other equipment in fact practically
the only exception have been hungary
which has pledged to donate thousands of
liters of fuel but no weapons and spain
which has sent a shipment with some
vests some helmets and a lot of gloves
gowns and masks heaps of masks yeah yeah
the coronavirus kind i guess madrid
thinks that masks are better than
weapons for winning wars anyway we have
already told you in various videos that
spanish politics are going through a bit
of a rough patch lately
the point is that all these measures are
how the united states the european union
the united kingdom and all the allies
hope to punish russia for unleashing the
horror of war in ukraine and at the same
time limit its future threat but at this
point it's your turn what do you think
of the strategy being followed by the
allied countries what else do you think
they should do will it work will it fail
leave us your comments down below and of
course if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like and
subscribe to visualpolitik from all of
us here we wish strength and
encouragement to all the ukrainian
people in future videos we will tell you
about many other consequences that this
war will have for russia and for the
whole of europe all the best and see you
next time
[Music]